i'm jennifer neville and i'll do the
overview for our session in the
afternoon which we loosely called
clustering so we have these four great
speakers uh
peter bickle here from uc berkeley
andrea montanari from
stanford karl rove from university of
wisconsin madison and vahab murachny
who's from google who is asking the
google type questions this morning so i
have a little bit more formality than
michael for the overview
but i should warn you i'm not a
clustering
person
so
what i thought would be good to do would
be to give you
just a general sense of the dimensions
on which the people that are working on
clustering and networks how they're the
kinds of questions that they ask and how
they formulate the modeling and the
algorithmic approaches
to their problem
how they differ so that you have some
context to think about the talks that
we'll be we'll be having this afternoon
and hopefully that will facilitate some
questions that we can have afterwards
so
i originally thought i'd give you some
sort of basic introduction to
clustering work but we already heard
about some earlier uh in the day and
there's some introductions in the talks
this afternoon so i'll just say there's
a large body of work a lot of people
working on identifying communities or
clusters or groups and networks which
ranges from people that work on spectral
clustering we heard about modularity
maximization and mark newman's
work this morning and also stochastic
block models and of course there's a lot
more
and here are
from looking over the talks that are
going to be given after i finish
speaking uh here are some dimensions on
which people differ in terms of how they
approach this clustering problem
whether they're from the statistics
community or the computer science
machine learning community or whether
they're focused on scaling
to very large data sets
or if they're more theoretical computer
scientists so first and foremost how
people formulate their problem
definition as is maybe the
first
way that they sort of frame how they're
going to approach this problem of
clustering and obviously how to define
what is a cluster is a hard problem that
exists not even you know
in the networks community but in the
people that look at data at large
so then
certain
types of work differ based on the kind
of data assumptions they make about the
underlying model of the data and we
talked about that a little bit this
morning
there's modeling assumptions that people
make
to
that may be different from these data
assumptions based on how they're going
to
algorithmically estimate their models
how the models are evaluated or
in terms of accuracy or the properties
of the models that there's that's
another dimension and finally what
people care about in terms of scaling or
asymptotics that differs as well
so
just a few quick comments on each of
these dimensions
today
in the talks we're going to hear both
about
people that look for global clusterings
of the entire network
into
either distinct partitions so we want to
have separate groups of the nodes where
each node only belongs to a single group
or we might want overlapping clusters
where nodes can belong to more than one
group and then we're also going to hear
several talks that focus at least
somewhat on local clustering because if
you think about globe clustering all of
the data into groups that might not be
feasible if you have a really large
data set maybe the
first of all
in terms of algorithmically you might
not want to spend enough time to cluster
a graph with a billion vertices but also
the groups might not make sense if you
consider the entire entire structure
so
in terms of the data assumptions
i guess because i'm a person that works
more on predictive modeling i always
think about learning a model that's
going to generalize to some new data
that we haven't seen before but the
interesting thing about clustering
particularly in networks is that there
it's really more of a descriptive task
where we want to model the data that we
have and describe the data that we see
and so we don't necessarily care about
generalizing to
new data that we haven't seen
but we
want to talk about the properties of the
algorithms or the types of clusters we
see under some assumptions about what
the data
have actually been generated from and so
this relates to kind the topics that we
talked about earlier
in the day because we might think about
analyzing clustering methods by assuming
that the data was generated from some
underlying parametric model and then if
that actually holds what can we say
about the kinds of things that our
algorithms were produced
other times we try to make fewer
assumptions about the data
but we might give some kind of bounds on
the performance of the algorithms
where some part of the bound includes
some characteristic of the graph for
example the conductance of the graph
in terms of
modeling assumptions first
if
people approach this from a more
parametric model based
framework then how what assumptions we
make about the characteristics of the
models might influence the
performance of the algorithm and we
heard a little bit of talk about that
this morning
in the difference between considering
smooth functions versus
non-smooth functions for these bernoulli
random variables that would generate the
edges
the dimension on which this the
the talks we're going to hear today
mostly differ
i think
really can be sort of ground out in our
choice of the objective function that we
maximize in our algorithms and so some
examples of objective functions are the
modularity function that was mentioned
earlier we could talk about cuts or
conductance but also the likelihood of
the data and the choice of the objective
function is often sort of intimately
tied to our problem definition because
if we say
that we want to have groups of nodes
such that they have a lot of links
inside their clusters and few links
outside their clusters then naturally
the way that we could formulate that
quantitatively is by considering the
cuts between the clusters
okay
and then in terms of evaluation
uh there's two
major uh dimensions that i saw in
people's talks for today and one talks
more about the correctness or
consistency of the algorithms so that in
some cases with some assumptions about
the data we want to guarantee that the
algorithm is going to find and return
the correct clusters to us
or maybe to have some sort of bound on
the approximation
quality of the output clusters
under the assumption that there exists a
cluster in the data okay and so that's
more on the properties of the kinds of
output clusters that we get but also of
concern is really the efficiency of the
algorithms and so we might want to have
some kind of guarantees that the
algorithm is going to scale linearly or
log linearly with the size of the data
or we'll hear with some of the people
that talk about local clustering maybe
to have a more efficient algorithm we
want to talk about having that scale
linearly in the size of the clusters
local clusters that we find rather than
the size of the overall graph and
something that i think is a sort of
tricky subject with respect to
clustering and i didn't see a lot in
people's slides
when i was looking through them for
today so hopefully maybe we can talk
about this more in the discussion but
really
there's not a lot of work on
validation of these clusters
in terms of whether they mean
what we hope they should mean about the
the data so are the groups or
communities are they meaningful we tend
to have the circular kind of argument
that we sort of formulate the problem
quantitatively
saying we want lots of links inside the
cluster a few links outside the cluster
then we frame that in a quantitative
objective function then we apply our
algorithm and then we measure how well
did we match that objective function and
so we have sort of a circular type of
evaluation normally and really
practitioners i think really would care
more about are these clusters meaningful
and are these communities sort of
important things in the data that we
have particularly when they reply
apply to people or social networks
okay and so the last dimension was
really
scaling or asymptotics i think there's
an interesting difference between the
algorithmic computer scientists that
talk about as asymptotics in terms of
run time and how fast the algorithm is
going to grow
and these statisticians that think more
about asymptotics in terms of thinking
about the estimation behavior of the
algorithm and so i'd like to see a
little bit more discussion about you
know are these orthogonal to each other
or
are there interactions between these two
typically
i myself if i have my statistician hat
on i say i don't really care about the
scaling to the really large graphs
because i really want to understand the
properties of how the statistical
estimation works and then later on once
we understand it we'll figure out how to
make it linear or log linear so it'll
scale to really large graphs
so that's all i have to say about
the overview i would say that the talks
will here will highlight through
different view different
frames of reference in terms of these
perspectives and then we can sort of
consider this further as we talk about
it in the discussion afterwards so i
will stop there and pass it on to peter
bickle who will be our first
talk